[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Anne Gellinek
[Musik]
guten Abend die rot-grün-gelbe Koalition
ist als Klima rettungskoalition
angetreten so steht es im
Koalitionsvertrag doch bevor es mit der
Rettung richtig losgehen konnte kam der
ukrainekrieg und auf einmal bestimmen
die Gasreserven der Welt den Reiseplan
von Kanzler und klimaminister natürlich
kann man der Regierung nicht vorwerfen
dass sie sich um Energie fürs Land
kümmert nur punkten kann Deutschland
damit auf der UN-Klimakonferenz eben
auch nicht Tag 2 des Bundeskanzlers in
Ägypten an dem er sich mit seiner
Lieblingsidee dem sogenannten klimaklub
Beschäftigte und sich auch mit dem
äußerst schwierigen Gastgeber anlegte
culine Atay berichtet aus Sharm el
Sheikh
lasst ihn frei das Motto der Einladung
im deutschen Pavillon der Klimakonferenz
und für seine Freilassung hat die
Schwester des demokratieaktivisten Allah
abdelfaltar ebenfalls Dissidentin enorme
Risiken auf sich genommen und ist nach
Sharm el Sheikh gereist
ihr Bruder einer der Ikonen des
arabischen Frühlings 2011 ist dabei im
Gefängnis zu sterben er nimmt seit
Wochen keine Nahrung mehr zu sich nun
auch kein Wasser mehr
ungewohnt deutlich forderte der
Bundeskanzler bei seinem Treffen mit dem
ägyptischen Präsidenten die Freilassung
des Aktivisten
es ist sehr bedrückend zu sehen dass
hier ein Menschenleben gefährdet ist und
der Hungerstreik ist jetzt in einem
Stadium getreten wo wir alle befürchten
müssen dass das wirklich zu ganz
furchtbaren Konsequenzen führt deshalb
habe ich und wie ich weiß auch noch
viele andere Staats- und Regierungschefs
das konkret angesprochen im Bereich
Wirtschaft ist das deutsche ägyptische
Verhältnis hingegen derzeit tadellos
dank eines milliardenvertrags darf die
Deutsche Bahn Ägyptens erstes
Hochgeschwindigkeitsnetz betreiben
außerdem sollen dank deutscher Hilfe
ägyptische flüssiggasexporte möglich
werden und will man gemeinsam in Ägypten
grünen Wasserstoff entwickeln
fossile und erneuerbare Energien
gleichzeitig kein Widerspruch für den
Kanzler
das ist verantwortlich gerade auch dann
wenn man auf dem richtigen Weg ist
nämlich aus den
fossilen Ressourcen auszusteigen sich
unabhängig von solchen Importen zu
machen auch in Afrika führt Scholz
doppelgleisig er kündigte heute an Kenia
beim Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien zu
unterstützen zugleich investiert er im
Senegal in die Erschließung neuer
Gasfelder
wenn als Deutschland und auch vielleicht
andere europäische Länder herkommen und
jetzt vor allen Dingen in gas
investieren damit wir das Gas nach
Europa importieren und verbrauchen dann
hat es die große Gefahr dass man so ein
Land wie Senegal wirklich in diese
fossilen Energien reinbringt dabei ist
es viel wichtiger dass wir fossina gehen
einsparen und das durch erneuerbar
ersetzen und dann eben auch Länder wie
sehen egal bei einem sauberen
Energiepfad unterstützen am Ende des
Tages bekommt Scholz eine Bühne um für
seine Idee eines klimaklubs zu werden
das Ziel gemeinsame Regeln um zu
verhindern dass die Industrie abwandert
in Länder mit niedrigeren
klimasstandards Indien und China in
diesem klimaklub mit hineinzuholen das
bleibt derzeit noch ein Wunschtraum für
Scholz und die G7 Länder
seit dem amerikanischen Bürgerkrieg vor
über 150 Jahren ist es fast immer so
dass die Partei die den US-Präsidenten
stellt bei den halbzeitwahlen im
Parlament verliert das war bei Trump so
bei Obama und bei Clinton in dessen
erster Amtszeit die Folge weniger
Handlungsspielraum Machtkampf Stillstand
es sieht so aus als ob es auch für den
Demokraten Joe Biden so kommen könnte
dessen Zustimmungswerte ziemlich im
Keller sind aber noch läuft die
Abstimmung in den USA und wird
beobachtet von Marietta Slomka die für
uns nach Washington gereist ist hallo
Marietta in Washington was macht diese
amerikanischen Zwischenwahlen so
besonders interessant und wichtig
hallo Washington ja das sind in der Tat
keine normalen mit Termin elections weil
die politischen Zeiten ja einfach nicht
mehr normal sind dazu muss man sich nur
an das erinnern was an dem berühmten
Gebäude hier hinter mir vor inzwischen
bald zwei Jahren geschehen ist der Sturm
aufs Kapitol am 6 Januar 2021 ich meine
das war ein versuchter Staatsstreichen
einer der ältesten Demokratien der Welt
und die Wahlen heute sind die ersten
seit dieser Zäsur und insofern ist das
schon auch eine Abstimmung darüber wie
die Amerikaner zu ihrer Demokratie und
ihrem Parlament stehen
gewählt wird heute das gesamte
Abgeordnetenhaus außerdem ein Drittel
des Senats der zweiten Kammer des
us-parlaments in dem die Bundesstaaten
vertreten sind und in den Bundesstaaten
werden außerdem noch jede Menge
Gouverneurs Posten gewählt und welche
Weichen dargestellt werden und warum das
für die politische Zukunft nicht nur der
USA so wichtig ist erklärt uns Claudia
Bates
hier haben sie den Daumen auf dem Geld
der Kongress segnet wichtige Ausgaben ab
wenn die Republikaner die Mehrheit haben
wenn sie die Pläne von Präsident beiden
stoppen so gut es geht ob es um
Schuldenpolitik geht um den Haushalt
Ausgaben fürs Klima oder höhere Steuern
den Demokraten das Regieren schwer
machen wäre das Ziel aus Präsident
beiden würden sie eine wie man es hier
nennt lahme Ente machen
die parlamentarischen Untersuchungen zum
Sturm aufs Kapitol würden beendet
stattdessen wird es Lärm geben Spektakel
Störfeuer und Ablenkung
if the mark Stream wenn die extremeren
Republikaner mehr Einfluss haben wird
das Repräsentantenhaus radikaler wir
werden viele Untersuchungen sehen gegen
den Präsidenten seine Familie das
Justizministerium gewinnen die
Republikaner das Repräsentantenhaus
werden Sie diese Bühne nutzen um den
gesellschaftlichen Diskurs zu
beherrschen
Thema Abtreibung das Oberste Gericht hat
das liberale Abtreibungsrecht gekippt
viele Republikaner möchten Abtreibung
nun grundsätzlich verbieten dagegen
würde Präsident beiden ein Veto einlegen
aber seine eigenen Pläne ein liberales
Abtreibungsrecht in ein Gesetz zu gießen
wären ebenso chancenlos
Thema Wirtschaft die Lebensmittelpreise
und Benzinpreise treiben das
republikanische narrativ
Inflation die Mehrheit der Amerikaner
glaubt sogar das Land sei in einer
Rezession obwohl das gar nicht stimmt
Thema Demokratie in den Bundesstaaten
stehen hunderte Republikaner zur Wahl
die die der großen und widerlegten Lüge
von Donald Trump anhängen die letzte
Wahl sei ihm gestohlen worden Menschen
wie Kristina caramo die Innenministerin
von Michigan werden möchte und dann dort
maßgeblichen Einfluss auf die Abläufe
der nächsten Präsidentschaftswahl hätte
und darauf am Ende festzustellen wer in
ihrem Staat gewonnen hat
ihr wisst warum ich in dieses Rennen
eingestiegen bin die Korruption in
unserem Wahlsystem ist eine Bedrohung
für die nationale Sicherheit
caramo hat jetzt schon geklagt gegen
zehntausende bereits eingegangener
Briefwahlstimmen Briefwahl traditionell
stärker genutzt von demokratischen
Wählern
wenn viele Wahl Leugner Positionen
gewinnen regional und lokal hilft das
ohne Zweifel den Republikanern bei der
nächsten Präsidentschaftswahl Trump
braucht Leute auf Schlüsselpositionen
die loyal sind und die Wahlen so
organisieren dass es ihm hilft oder die
ihn im Zweifelsfall einfach zum Gewinner
in diesem Staat erklären
die Wahlen werden also zeigen wo das
Land hinsteuert sie könnten den Boden
bereiten für eine weitere Kandidatur von
Donald Trump der schon mehr als nur
Andeutungen Macht über dieses Vorhaben
und damit gleich die Frage an unseren
usa-korrespondenten MRT wir sind also
die beiden stehen ja heute nicht auf dem
Wahlzettel Trump und beiden aber es
könnte indirekt doch auch eine
Abstimmung über diese zwei sein oder ich
glaube den Republikanern ist es gelungen
dass zu einer Abstimmung über Joe Biden
zu machen weil das Thema Wirtschaft eben
das Wichtigste ist und da geben die
Amerikaner Joe Biden schlechte
Punktzahlen und Donald Trump wartet nur
darauf dass es eine Abstrafung gibt für
Joe Biden weil er will am 15 also
nächste Woche Dienstag eine große
Neuigkeit verkünden so hat er jedenfalls
angekündigt manche rechnen damit dass er
tatsächlich seine Kandidatur bekannt
geben wird für die Präsidentschaft ich
glaube es hängt aber wirklich von den
Ergebnissen ab also wenn es ihm gelingt
möglichst viele seiner Anhänger
trumpisten hier in den Kongress zu
bekommen die dann Joe Biden unter Druck
setzen können in den nächsten zwei
Jahren und gleichzeitig auch in den
Ämtern in den Bundesstaaten Gouverneure
Innenminister Justizminister genügend da
sind die im Zweifel selbst wenn er
verlieren würde in zwei Jahren doch noch
ins Amt helfen könnten ich glaube dann
wird der nächste Woche Kandidatur
bekannt geben jetzt nochmal auf die
mitteams heute so richtig rosig sieht
für die Demokraten ja nicht aus also
nach dem was man zumindest so ein
Prognosen liest und hört sehr eindeutig
nämlich sehr schlecht für die Demokraten
aber wir wissen aus unseren Reisen das
ganz offenbar den Demokraten ist
gelungen ist sehr sehr viele Wähler
alleine im Bundesstaat Arizona mehrere
10.000 30.000 neu zu registrieren das
sind neue Wähler die vorher nicht
gewählt haben und die sind im Grunde
genommen unbeschriebene Blätter für die
Wahlforscher das heißt man weiß nicht in
welche Richtung das geht und die können
in diesen engen Ergebnissen wirklich
einen Unterschied machen und das zweite
ist viele Menschen weigern sich den
Wahlforschern Auskunft zu geben in
dieser polarisierten Stimmung ob sie für
den einen oder den anderen Stimmen
werden also könnten die Umfragen
vielleicht auch nicht stimmen darauf
setzen die Demokraten aber zum Schluss
muss man sagen es ist wohl mehr Hoffnung
als Realität dass die Menschen in diesem
Land was ja eigentlich so frei und und
kommunikationsfreudig ist plötzlich sehr
schmale übrig zum Teil wenn du über ihre
politischen Ideen und ihre wahlabsichten
die redest das habe ich auch jetzt
gerade festgestellt dass weil eine
Erfahrung die ich gemacht habe als ich
hier in Virginia unterwegs war das ist
im Speckgürtel von Washington
kein Wunder dass es so viele nach lauden
County zieht weil es so schön ist die
perfekte amerikanische Idylle in den
letzten 20 Jahren hat sich die
Einwohnerzahl hier verdoppelt lauden
County eine Stunde Autofahrt von
Washington ist eine der wohlhabendsten
Landkreise Amerikas und politisch noch
in demokratische Hand im Café genießen
Sie die letzten Sonnenstrahlen dieses
Herbstes doch wie angespannt die
Atmosphäre unter der Oberfläche ist
erzählen uns die beiden
immobilienmaklerinnen Rachel und hier
colia
so ein gespaltenes Land sind ist es für
mich echt schwer geworden eigene
politische Ansichten zu äußern weil ich
damit sofort die Hälfte der Leute
entweder vor den Kopf stoße oder happy
machen
ein Eiertanz ist das es sind wirklich
stressige Zeiten
auf diesem Stress hat Barista Marius
seine eigene Konsequenz gezogen er will
nicht mal mehr wählen gehen obwohl er
Politik studierte und sich in der
Lokalpolitik engagieren wollte bevor er
hier im Café anfing selbst zu der Lüge
von den gestohlenen
Präsidentschaftswahlen hat er keine
eigene Meinung mehr
weil wir in diesem Fake News Zeitalter
leben finde ich es wirklich schwer zu
entscheiden was wahr ist und was nicht
die einen sagen so die anderen sagen so
ich weiß nicht mehr wer Recht hat
die Flut an diesinformation hat ihn vor
allem demotiviert
Verunsicherung Spaltung und obendrauf
die Inflation vor allem die hohen
Spritpreise sorgen auch in einer
wohlhabenden pendlerstadt verärgert
auch in der Restaurantkette fort-check
ist die Krise zu spüren
Eigentümer Tony Stafford macht sich eine
Menge Sorgen um sein Unternehmen für die
Preissteigerungen macht er die beiden
Regierung verantwortlich er ist eh
trump-fan nicht mit allem einverstanden
aber Trump habe sein Bestes gegeben
der Sturm aufs Kapitol am 6 Januar das
war allerdings auch für ihn beängstigend
ich war damals hier im Restaurant und
habe mich geschenkt ich bin sehr
patriotisch und das ist nicht Amerika
das war enttäuschend und traurig
das Donald Trump mit dem Putschversuch
etwas zu tun hatte will er aber trotzdem
nicht glauben
für die Demokratin Phillis Randall steht
das natürlich außer Frage seit 2015 ist
sie hier die Landrätin die erste
schwarze Frau in diesem Amt die
Feindseligkeit ihr gegenüber habe enorm
zugenommen
aggressiven Mails die ich bekomme den
täglichen Hass das gab es so vorher
nicht das ist relativ neu seit zwei drei
Jahren und ja das macht mir große Sorgen
aber dennoch glaubt sie an ihr Land
ich glaube an unsere Demokratie und ich
glaube sie ist das Wert für sie zu
kämpfen
wir sind gerade in einer sehr
gefährlichen Situation einem sehr
gefährlichen Moment
aber wir können vom Abgrund noch zurück
diese Wahlen jetzt werden entscheidend
sein sie werden Geschichte schreiben
und über die Bedeutung dieser Wahlen
wollen wir mit einem amerikanischen
Politologen sprechen jeffree raski ist
bei uns er war für das
US-Außenministerium fast 25 Jahren
diplomatischen Dienst unter anderem bei
der NATO und in Deutschland und ist
jetzt Präsident der Instituts für
deutsch-amerikanische Studien an der
Johns Hopkins Universität hier in
Washington vielen dank vielen Dank fürs
Kommen ich habe das eben in dieser
demokratischen Politikerin die wir
Landrätin die wir getroffen haben fand
das sehr berührend dass sie sagte das
ist eine historische Wahl das hier steht
wirklich viel auf dem Spiel würden sie
diese Einschätzung teilen die absolut es
steht ganz viel auf dem Spiel kurz und
mittelfristig geht es um die um die
Legislative um die Kontrolle über die
Tagesordnung und über die Gesetzes
Gesetzgebung für Präsidenten beiden
längerfristig geht es um die
Positionierung für die
Präsidentschaftswahlen 2024 und wir
haben schon gehört es gibt
wahrscheinlich eine Kandidatur von
Donald Trump das heißt wir stehen vor
gravierenden Ereignissen die die USA die
nächsten Jahre prägen werden und das
fängt alles mit es bringt nicht heute an
aber heute ist ein ganz wichtiger Tag
und diese Einschätzung dass die die
Demokratie ein Stück weit in Gefahr ist
also ist ja doch ein wenig bedrückend
sage ich mal dass eine Mehrheit der eine
große Mehrheit sogar der
republikanischen Kandidaten die heute
antreten sei es Senats sei es das
Repräsentantenhaus um sogenannte
election die neue sind das ist könnte
man uns Deutsche vielleicht am ersten
mit Wahlniederlagen nicht anerkennen
übersetzen also die sagen also
eigentlich wurde unseren Trump die Wahl
gestohlen und wir erkennen eigentlich
auch Joe beiden nicht an das ist doch
eigentlich ein Grundprinzip der
Demokratie in Niederlage anzuerkennen ja
das ist ein Phänomen dass wir schon in
den in den letzten paar Jahren bemerkt
haben da dass da muss man damit kämpfen
da gibt es schon eine Reihe von
juristischen Verfahren und das wird ein
ein langer harter Kampf sein das
kann man nicht drumherum reden man will
jetzt auch keine Schreckgespenster an
die Wand werfen also manche Beobachter
sprechen ja schon von einem civil war
das ist das Marktfläche übertrieben sein
aber das ist mehr Gewalt in der
Gesellschaft geben kann mehr Attentate
wir hatten gerade das Attentat auf den
Ehemann von Nancy Pelosi der der
Sprecherin des Repräsentantenhauses
teilen Sie solche Befürchtungen das mehr
Gewalt in die amerikanische Gesellschaft
kommen kann
wir haben auch festgestellt dass seit
dem 6 januar und und diese Attacke auf
dem auf das Kapitol dass die dass die
Behörden viel aufmerksamer geworden sind
und da werden wir auch sehen dass die
auch versuchen diese Lage unter
Kontrolle zu halten insofern von von
solchen Zuständen würde ich im Moment
nicht sprechen aber natürlich muss man
das in acht haben und darauf reagieren
sobald es Hinweise gibt es das Gewalt
bedroht oder angewendet wird sind ja vor
allem auch ein außenpolitikexperte und
waren auch lange in Moskau langen Europa
was bedeutet diese Wahl für uns Europäer
denn das ist ja auch etwas was ich das
deutsche Publikum fragt wie wird die
Außenpolitik sich eventuell verändern
wenn das Haus zum Beispiel also der in
Kongress die die das Abgeordnetenhaus
dann republikanisch geprägt ist also der
Effekt von zum Beispiel wenn wir
annehmen dass die Republikaner eins oder
zwei Kammern
erobern wird das natürlich Einfluss auf
die Innenpolitik haben in erster Linie
in der Außenpolitik ist der Präsident
bei uns mit erheblichen Mächten
ausgestattet und er wird diese diese
Mächte dann
anwenden wenn wir zum Beispiel von der
von dem
Russlands gegen die Ukraine sprechen
es ist wohlmöglich dass die dass der
Kongress in den kommenden Wochen das
heißt vor bevor der neuen
Legislaturperiode ein eine neue
Hilfspaket verabschiedet das heißt der
dem Präsidenten mit mit Mitteln
aufstatten damit er seine Politik weiter
verfolgen kann und insofern muss man
sagen also in der Außenpolitik wird
beiden weiter Kurs fahren dass das für
dich egal was der Ausgang bei dieser
Wahl sein wird das könnte sich dann erst
vielleicht nach dem
Präsidentschaftswahlen miteinander
sitzen das hatte Kevin me cassiday ja
vielleicht dann der nächste Führer im
Repräsentantenhaus wird gesagt also ein
Blankoscheck für die Ukraine und den
wird es mit uns nicht geben ist das
jetzt Wahlkampfgetöse oder müssen die
Ukraine da vielleicht doch was
fürchterung haben er hat nicht gesagt
dass wir kein Mittel finden zur
Verfügung stellen er hat gesagt kein
mehr Kontrolle vielleicht aber wenn wenn
die Demokraten in den nächsten sechs
Wochen
zig Milliarden an den Präsidenten geben
für diese Unterstützung dann ist der
Präsident für die kommenden zehn zwölf
Monate dann in der Lage der Ukraine
militärisch und auch also Makro oder
finanzpolitisch zu unterstützen
Dankeschön die Einschätzung eines
Amerikaners mit weitem Blick auch auf
Europa und und Deutschland vielen dank
der frühjahrski fürs hier sein vielen
Dank fürs und während Deutschland dann
irgendwann nachher schläft werden wir
hier natürlich beobachten wie die ersten
Wahlergebnisse einlaufen insgesamt
übrigens aus sechs Zeitzonen und morgen
abend um diese Zeit wissen wir dann
jedenfalls schon mehr und melden uns
dann von hier auch wieder mit einem
heute journal aus Washington DC aber
geben jetzt erstmal zurück zu einer nach
Mainz
vielen Dank Marietta und das heute
journal Update um 0 Uhr schläft
natürlich nicht und hält sie über die
Zwischenwahlen auf dem Laufenden und hat
vielleicht schon erste Trends
der Ausgang der Wahl in den USA könnte
wir haben es gehört Konsequenzen für die
amerikanische Außenpolitik haben der
Fraktionschef der Republikaner hat
bereits damit gedroht die Militärhilfe
für die Ukraine einschränken zu wollen
nach dem Motto America first was geht
uns die Ukraine an Europa wäre mit der
Unterstützung der Ukraine plötzlich
allein zu Haus auch wenn wir erst in ein
paar Wochen oder Monaten wissen was
reale Politik wird unterdessen zieht
sich der Krieg in die Länge die
britische Aufklärung will wissen dass
Soldaten auf russischer Seite der Front
bei Mariupol Panzersperren errichten
wohl weil sie eine ukrainische Eroberung
fürchten gleichzeitig geht der
Dauerbeschuss ukrainischer Orte weiter
daran Hassan Sade berichtet aus Nikopol
streunende Hunde zurückgelassen von
ihren Besitzern von ehemals 100.000
Bewohnern in nicopol sind 80.000
geflüchtet wer konnte hat die Stadt
verlassen wer geblieben ist ist meist
alt
wir werden jeden Tag beschossen unser
Haus wurde direkt getroffen und jetzt
räumen wir die Trümmer Weg mein Mann
macht das ein paar Freunde helfen
die Stadt ist in Reichweite der
russischen Artillerie die Einschläge
kommen von der anderen Seite des Flusses
knipro dort steht auch das größte
Atomkraftwerk Europas es ist von der
russischen Armee besetzt und produziert
nur noch Strom für die eigene Kühlung
die russische Armee beschicht uns mit
Artillerie vom Gelände des AKWs sie
bewahren dort ihre Munition und
Ausrüstung auf das AKW ist de facto zu
einem Militärstützpunkt geworden wir
wissen das und unsere Position bleibt
dieselbe unsere Militär ist es verboten
das Gelände des AKWs oder Bereiche in
der Nähe unter Beschuss zu nehmen dieses
Verbot ist nicht diskutabel
so sind der ukrainischen Armee hier die
Hände gebunden und echten Schutz bieten
den Menschen vor allem öffentliche
Bunker Holzplatten und Stühle dienen als
Betten Raum für 80 Menschen die
Schlafplätze sind fest vergeben
sie kommen jede Nacht weil sie uns jede
Nacht bombardieren von drüben aus
endorada
sie sammeln Laub als ob es ihr größtes
Problem sei sie bauen tagsüber auf was
zuvor zerstört wurde es ist ein
Kreislauf in diesem Krieg hier in
nicopol durchbrochen werden kann er wohl
nur am Verhandlungstisch
jeder Krieg endet mit Verhandlungen die
einzige Frage ist nur zu welchen
Bedingungen zu welchem Kompromiss man
kommt sprechen wir von lokaler Ebene
dann müssen wir über das Atomkraftwerk
und das umliegende Gebiet verhandeln
eine Demilitarisierung des
Atomkraftwerks würde den Menschen hier
viele Sorgen nehmen nicht nur Ihnen
wenn man sich den Rat von Experten holt
dann muss man damit leben dass sie Dinge
empfehlen die man vielleicht selbst gar
nicht so gut findet so geschehen bei den
fünf Wirtschaftsweisen drei Frauen und
zwei Männer die die Bundesregierung
beraten sie verwarfen heute offenbar
vieles was die Koalition vorhat statt
die Bürger gleichmäßig mit der Gießkanne
zu entlasten solle die Regierung doch
bitte die Besserverdienenden zur Kasse
bitten und zwar entweder mit einer
vorübergehenden Erhöhung des
Spitzensteuersatzes oder einem
energiesoli fragen wir doch unsere
Wirtschaftsweise Valerie Haller wie
kommen denn diese expertenvorschläge an
der Börse an Steuererhöhungen kommen
bekanntlich an der Börse ja wirklich
selten gut an entsprechend schaffwelt
auch die Kritik aus die kommt von
verschiedenen Seiten von
Wirtschaftsinstituten beispielsweise
besonders scharf aber reagiert der
Mittelstand nicht allein gut verdienende
Angestellte und Beamte werden durch sie
besteuert sondern auch die zigt sondern
von Unternehmern die gerade verzweifelt
versuchen ihre Firmen und damit
hunderttausende ihre Arbeitsplätze durch
die Energiekrise zu retten die
Vorschläge enthalten viel politischen
Sprengstoff die Energiekrise soll nach
Ansicht der Wirtschaftsweisen für den
Staat bezahlbarer werden aber auch
sozialer denn vom Gießkannen Prinzip der
Entlastungen profitieren eben alle nicht
nur die Bedürftigen deshalb pochen die
Wirtschaftsweisen auf Steuererhöhungen
oder einen energie-soli für besser
verdienende dies würde dazu beitragen
die Zielgenauigkeit des Gesamtpakets aus
Entlastungen und Belastungen zu erhöhen
und zu signalisieren dass die
Energiekrise solidarisch bewältigt
werden muss in diesem Gutachten
demonstrieren die Wirtschaftsweisen
ungewöhnliche Einigkeit das war in den
vergangenen Jahren anders als der
Sachverständigenrat sogar regelrecht
verkracht war doch mit Vielstimmigkeit
findet man kaum Gehör diese Erkenntnis
hat sich der Sachverständigenrat wohl am
Herzen genommen danke Valerie an die
Börse nach Frankfurt und wir machen
weiter mit den Nachrichten und Heinz
Wolf und wir bleiben bei der Wirtschaft
nach dem umstrittenen China-Geschäft im
Hamburger Hafen ist jetzt der mögliche
Verkauf einer chipfertigung des
Dortmunder Unternehmens elmos in der
Diskussion
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck verwies bei
Bereichen kritische Sektoren wie
Halbleiter und Chips auf höhere Hürden
für chinesische Investments und das
schließe für ihn elmos mit ein offenbar
soll bereits morgen das Bundeskabinett
über ein Verkaufsverbot entscheiden
bundesinnenministerin Phaser und
BKA-Chef Münch haben eine neue Studie zu
Sicherheit und Kriminalität in
Deutschland vorgestellt Ergebnis einer
Befragung zu persönlichen Erfahrungen
und zum Sicherheitsgefühl laut der
Studie bewegt sich das Sicherheitsgefühl
der Bevölkerung insgesamt auf einem
hohen Niveau allerdings meiden in der
Dunkelheit 44% aller Befragten bestimmte
Orte und 37% den öffentlichen Nahverkehr
bei Frauen liegen diese Werte deutlich
höher bei 58 bzw 52 Prozent am
häufigsten berichteten die Befragten
über Straftaten im Internet Angst vor
Betrug dort haben 42 Prozent und 27%
machen keine Geldgeschäfte über das
Internet
in Niedersachsen ist Ministerpräsident
weil vom Landtag erneut in sein Amt
gewählt und vereidigt worden der
SPD-Politiker startet damit in seine
dritte Amtszeit die neue rot-grüne
Landesregierung will noch in diesem
Monat ein rund eine Milliarde Euro
schweres
energieentlastungspaket auf dem Weg
bringen weitere Schwerpunkte sollen etwa
der Ausbau erneuerbarer Energien sowie
mehr bezahlbarer Wohnraum sein
ein Ergebnis aus der Fußball-Bundesliga
von heute abend Wolfsburg hat gegen
Borussia Dortmund 2:0 gewonnen die
deutschen Handballerinnen bereiten sich
bei der EM auf ihr letztes und
entscheidendes Gruppenspiel vor morgen
Abend trifft die Mannschaft auf die WM
vierten aus Spanien dann geht es für Sie
um den Einzug in die Hauptrunde gestern
Abend hatte das DHB-Team sein zweites
EM-Spiel verloren die Mannschaft
unterlag Gastgeber Montenegro mit 25 zu
in der Toskana haben Archäologen einen
spektakulären Fund gemacht in einer
versiegelten Thermalanlage fanden sie 24
Bronzestatuen etruskischer Gottheiten
die mehr als 2000 Jahre alt sein sollen
durch den thermal-schlamm wurden die
Statue nahezu perfekt konserviert zudem
fanden die Forschenden tausende Münzen
aus Bronze Silber und Gold
das war es von uns morgen also ein heute
journal aus Washington mit Marietta
Slomka den Wahlergebnissen und Analysen
und wie gesagt später um 0.30 meldet
sich Gunter lagauße mit dem schnall
Update einen schönen Abend und tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend morgen überquert uns die
Kaltfront von tief philomena und bringt
uns auch Regen wenn die Kaltfront
abgezogen ist übernimmt hoch Charlie mit
Sonnenschein Nebel und Hochnebel der
Regen setzt schon heute Nacht im Westen
ein hier in Südostbayern bleibt es
trocken und da bildet sich Nebel bei
Temperaturen von +4 bis minus ein Grad
sonst bleiben die Nachttemperaturen
milder und morgen liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 11 und 16
Grad und der Regen der Nacht zieht
weiter ostwärts an kräftigsten regnet es
im Schwarzwald hier in Südost Bayern
kommt der Regen morgen noch gar nicht an
nachmittags geht es dann Schauer und
Gewitter an der Nordseeküste und dann
wird es von Tag zu Tag sonniger und
ruhiger da ist auf lange Frist jetzt
aber immer kälter wird lohnt gerade ganz
besonders ein Blick in die Erde tief
unten ist es heiß mit dieser natürlichen
Energie können wir klimafreundlich
heizen bis zu 6 km tiefe Bohrungen sind
nötig um Geothermie zu nutzen Wasser
wird dazu in 200 Grad heißen
Gesteinsschichten erw woanders findet
sich direkt warmes Thermalwasser zum
anzapfen für Fernwärme oder um Strom zu
erzeugen abgekühltes Wasser gelangt nach
unten ein Kreislauf entsteht
geothermisch besonders interessant sind
Norddeutschland der Oberrhein und das
Alpenvorland mehr auch zu den Risiken in
einer halben Stunde bei lashscosmos
guten Abend